This is the Chris Abraham show.
Hey there.
Welcome to Chris Abraham show.
The Chris Abraham show formerly
known as Chris cast.
Today is season 5 episode 20,
that is 20 and I don't know when
I'm going to stop season 5 so
that is bent, they write bente.
Isn't that 20 bente or is it?
Um Bryson, is it wrightson?
Hegel?
What is German for 20?
In German that's sensation.
Responsive.
No.
Thank you fun.
Seek its fancy smancy.
Seonsuk hey Google.
What's 20 in French in French
that's vent.
What else should I translate?
Nothing sure I'll stop
translating.
I save that is in it van in
French.
That's the what else should I
translate?
Isn't it van or is it full?
Miss Penn movie.
Wizard elephant.
Okay.
Quoi.
Genset back to D to me d.
Key?
What?
I don't know what you say.
You tell me I sound like an
idiot.
Stop translating.
Video.
I hate it.
Sure, I'll stop translating.
Thank you.
Well, I could restart this
episode but I think you guys
find this kind of thing funny.
So I was working yesterday from
Starbucks and my lovely friend,
Jason came in and we chatted.
And he asked me about the guest
me about the cop podcast.
And when I was on the phone with
my friend, Linda, I found out
that she was listening to me on,
on, on speaker mode and that she
had Amazon Echoes or whatever
they're called.
And I I said, Alexa play the
latest episode of the Chris
Abraham show.
Alexa play the latest episode of
the Chris Abraham show.
Getting the Chris Abraham show
from Amazon music.
Here's season 5 episode 19.
S5e unwavering libertarian stand
unconditional support for
transgender rights, Alexis stop.
So I I was driven to make this
episode.
Now, I don't know when I'm going
to talk about, I didn't think
about it until just now.
I was cleaning dishes and pens,
and realize that I don't have
any fat or oil to treat my steel
and cast iron pans with.
So, I felt like a bad father.
My kids are apparently, my
bicycle, my dumbbells, my
kettlebells, my pens, my knives
in my guns.
So, I am a Catholic boy because
that's well over 10 things.
So I am a good Catholic.
I have many children But I've
been thinking about the fact
that everybody goes very quickly
to Chris, you carry water for
Putin.
I literally had my fraternity
brother, take me to dinner and
asked me point-blank, are you
being paid by the Russians for
what you're writing?
On social and Facebook and
Twitter and mastodons?
And my answer to him is do you
know anybody in Moscow?
Because I'm doing this for free
and Get a lot of this, even even
after the Durham the Durham,
right?
It's not Dunham.
It's after the Durham report.
And after it's been proven that,
all you have to do is tell, tell
somebody that you are a, you
carry water for Putin and you
are disgraced, right?
So that was the strategy by
Hillary Clinton against Trump or
Hillary Clinton's Camp against
Trump.
And we all know that the steel
dossier was BS and Russia, gate
was BS and PP tape is BS.
And just about every allegation
against anybody that they are,
in fact, carrying water for
Putin, or they are a Russian
asset is.
Merely mudslinging good
old-fashioned mudslinging.
You can tell because because
now, I saw someone in a on,
Mastodon, say that Jill Stein
and komal Diaz.
What's his name?
Hey, Gogol, who is the
Presidential nominee for the
Green Party?
Cornel West the website
ballotpedia dot-org, they say
the green party.
So no Alexis stop who's Court
Cornel West hey Google is Cornel
West.
Hey Google.
Who's Cornel West?
According to Wikipedia Cornell
Ronald West is an American
philosopher, political activist
social critic actor and public
intellectual the grandson.
Hey Google is Cornel West, a
Russian asset.
Sorry, I don't understand.
Hey, Gogol is Jill Stein, a
Russian asset.
According to Wikipedia in
October 20, 19.
Hillary Clinton said that Russia
is ongoing efforts to influence
us.
Elections included.
A plot to support a third party
candidate in 2020 which could
either be Jill Stein.
Whom she described as a Russian
asset or Tulsi gabbard.
Oh Hilary oh, Hillary Clinton
and resig, 80 Hillary Clinton.
0q, I don't know anything about
Jill Stein.
I know that she was Results on
search.
A Google stop.
Okay, stopping bows.
So at the end of the day I know.
Jill Stein was she part of the
Progressive Party, right?
She was or the hey, Google what
party was Jill Stein?
Part of just starting as a
member of the green party of the
United States and I remember
Jill Stein took votes away from
Hillary Clinton, right?
I don't know, but I found these
results on search.
Jill Stein cost, Hillary dearly
in 2016 denim demo.
So it's obviously a hit job.
If anybody calls you a water
carrier for Putin, it's not that
you're literally Hey Google, who
is the British person who is a
supporter of Hitler.
According to Wikipedia Unity
Valkyrie Freeman, mitford.
The 8th of August 1914, to the
28th of May 1948, was a British
socialite known for her
relationship with Adolf Hitler,
both in Great Britain, and
Germany.
She was a prominent supporter of
Nazism Fascism and anti-Semitism
and belong to Hitler's.
Inner circle of friends, why
don't remember?
But everybody always remember
from history class, where they
always used to tell me that
there was a British supporter or
in, they blur or appease or hey
Google who is the British
appeasement policy of Hitler
during before WWII On the
website.
IW m dot there, we are Neville,
Chamberlain instituted.
In the hope of avoiding War,
appeasement was the name given
to Britain's policy.
In the 1930s of allowing Hitler,
to expand German territory,
unchecked most closely
associated with British prime
minister Neville Chamberlain.
It is now widely discredited as
a policy of weakness.
So there we go.
So, Neville, Chamberlain is
hereby considered to be an
appeasement Britt and Neville
Chamberlain.
Is almost always used as a
parity and Echo, a comparison, a
useful tool to say that anybody
who is anti-ukrainian war or
anti-war in general, or doesn't
believe the narrative associated
with Ukraine, Russian conflict
or believes, even that the
imperial West spurred?
Hey Gogol, stop.
Okay.
Stopping off is display, so
annoying but also useful.
So there's my Paradox.
So it's such a shorthand, right?
It's such a shorthand that
anything that we want means that
you are a fascist and
everything.
You don't.
We don't want means that you are
an appeasement policy person.
Now, I feel very strongly about
All of these things but I don't
care one way or the other.
I'm only allergic to lying and
bullshitting and propaganda and
duplicity and hypocrisy.
I'm not pro anything.
I hate war and I feel like the
West had 25 years since the
discussion with Russia, then the
Soviet Union about Not moving,
Eastward past Eastern, Germany,
and not hegemonic Lee, including
eastern, central, eastern
Central, Europe, and Eastern
Europe in the in the board known
as the at that time.
NATO.
And then not much later known as
the European union.
Now, I wouldn't even care about
any of this stuff, but I lived
in Berlin and I got to see how
how much Ukraine in Eastern
Europe and Central Europe, even
Western Europe, how dependent
they were on Russian, gas and
oil, how you can very quickly.
Turn off all of Europe.
If you were to turn off the
pipelines coming from Russia,
gas, and oil.
And I Saw that countries like
Germany and France and a lot of
other countries had very
friendly relationships with the
former Soviet Union out of
necessity, right?
And this didn't stand very well
at all.
When it came to the people who
are writing the checks, which is
namely namely the United States
and and I guess You know
corporations but mostly mostly
you know Western borrowing
Western Banks, Western
investment and the military
industrial complex along with
taxpayer money and money
borrowed from China.
So I said to myself that this
isn't going to last this
friendly nature, this
friendliness with with with
Russia the fact that it's
Russian money was flowing into
the city of London and was
flowing into Paris and London
and Italy and Monaco, and the
French Riviera and Italy and
how, you know, even places like
so she and so forth were
becoming appealing to For a
cheap cheaper, more affordable.
Make there was there was really
a kind of de facto integration
and melding already between
Russia and Western Europe that
was completely uncomfortable.
I mean, Russia is patently,
Russia might be a serfdom
there's sir surely still rural
surf level people.
There are definitely rural Owls
and low caste and what would be
called.
Sit term for Rural like, hey
girl, what's the modern term for
were extremely rural or surf?
Modern surfs, I don't know.
But I found these results on
search.
Hey Google.
What is the concept of modern
Ser f?
On the website, web Dash
strategist.com, they say, a
modern-day surf is doing the
work for others, creating
content, creating data driving,
others around, managing physical
properties for rent.
So others can profit on
marketplaces and working for
others.
As a contractor without full
benefits.
I also paid Google.
What is Russia's modern
feudalism called?
I don't know, but I found these
results on search.
So anyway, I would the analogy
here is that Russia has become
an oligarchical.
Serfdom a futile, a feudalistic
society based on Modern
oligarchy, right?
And it is driven by Moscow and
st.
Petersburg is driven by, you
know, st.
Petersburg and Moscow.
And from there there are, you
know, mostly rural.
Areas that's mostly where the
population density is.
And over time the definition of
Russia as being a, an autocratic
North Korea type despotic Place.
Akin to hey, Google where's that
country?
Where all the cars have to be
white?
On the website are ferl dot-org.
They say, you can have whatever
color car you want in
Turkmenistan as long as it is
white.
So Putin is not a Turkmenistan
as despot.
He is a Russian to ignore you.
I'm going to ignore you.
So, even though Putin is being
painted as a Turkmenistan e
despot, he doesn't have any form
of Turkmenistan e despotism.
He is obviously, extremely
wealthy and benefits personally
from his 25-year leadership
whether or not.
He was the man as the president
or the men behind the president,
which happened during one ERM.
However, I mean, Nancy Pelosi
has a hundred million dollars.
So I would think that if Nancy
Pelosi spent another 25 years, I
feel like hey Google how much is
Obama Barack Obama worth On the
website go begging rates.com
they say Barack Obama's net
worth 70 million dollars,
celebrity net worth and Business
Insider have both reported the
former presidents.
Net worth is 70 million dollars.
People also asked hey Google how
much how much is Joe Biden's?
Personal net worth?
I don't know but I found these
results on search his net worth
in 2023 is 9 million dollars.
Who knows?
I don't know.
I'm just saying that that
there's no such thing as a
poverty present anymore.
There's no, there's no such
thing as a president of the
people.
I mean there's never been right?
Like the only thing
differentiating our president in
terms of to Two tier law is the
following.
The first one is if you say
you're not King, I guess you're
not King in the same way that
America has 1,000 bases around
the world and because we say
that we're not neo-colonialist
and that the countries where our
thousand base, our bases are
aren't our Neo colonies, just
because we say it, We're like,
no, we're a democracy.
No, we're exporting democracy.
No, we're just partners with
other Democratic countries that
are completely autonomous and
have complete personal agency.
If you say it aloud enough, it
has to be true.
So we are not modern Colonials
just like rate.
Britain is not is no longer a
durn colonial power and because
people say that Great Britain is
our poodle, it means that Great
Britain in the city of London
isn't actually are daddy where
it's Daddy and the power of
London is completely diminished.
And they don't barely mean
anything in the world and
they're just so sad especially
with brexit.
Like they're so sad, they're
just a little Island.
If you talk to Great Britain
they're like oh we're just a wee
Island, we don't have any power
globally.
We just are we we the sun is set
on our Wee Little.
Are we Little Island?
Oh we're just so Charming were
so Elizabethan.
Oh, we're just so cute.
Just like the Dutch.
Oh, we're just a Dutch.
We don't have Global interests
and petroleum completely.
We're not the most influential.
Country in the entire world,
dealing with metals and
resources and Mining and, and
building and oil and gas and
Shale, no, no, no, no, that's
silly.
We like we have a silly, funny
little royalty.
And we are based on the word.
Orange, isn't that cute?
So adorable, um, So if you say
it, it's true.
So because we say that Russia is
a, an authoritarian Nation,
where everybody is still
throwing to the gulag and
because even though all the
language, e, we use is patently
untrue because Russia collapsed
in 89 90 91 92 etcetera, and
because it hasn't been actively
communistic to Tha latarian
despotic.
It's cetera in 30 years.
But if you say it loud enough,
you can stoke the Cold War fears
there.
Just right under the surface and
since everybody in Congress is
over, 75 it over 60.
I mean I was alive and I was
alive during the Cold War.
Like I mean, it wasn't when I
was 19 20 21 when everything
collapsed but still You know in
my in my the first 19 18 19, 20
years of my life.
The the thermonuclear war was
nigh.
So and Berlin was spooky in
there was Eastern Western
Germany and Eastern Europe was
all black and white.
And everybody just drove around
and trabant Sandlot has and and
it was really sad and they were
pathetic and all their power
lifters were what trans women or
completely and we didn't think
that there were any beautiful
women.
There were no beautiful women
because always saw Were
powerlifters.
And so, we didn't know that
Eastern European women are
probably the most beautiful
women on earth, and probably the
smartest, and funniest, and
cleverest, and, and most lovely.
So that was propaganda.
And so, I don't know, right?
Like I feel like the woman on
Mastodon was throwing stones at
Jill Stein, calling her, a
Russian asset and then calling
Cornel, West, a Russian asset,
and I'm like, hey, lady, you're
a Russian ass hat, she didn't
get it because there's no humor
when you are a True Believer.
So, I called her a Russian ass
hat and she didn't get it but I
feel like I've been called a
Russian asked that a million
times.
I feel like if you're remotely
curious about the true number of
casualties and dead we know it's
probably between five and ten to
one and not in the direction
that the media is telling you
it's more like a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand
Dead ukrainians versus twenty
thousand right?
And so that means Ins 600,000,
casualties 200,000 dead.
I feel like the numbers are
swapped right.
Whatever the numbers are there.
Like no.
Let's swap it and make that the
Russian casualties.
So the latest news is that they
were saying this is the first
and worst humiliation that Putin
ever received which was the fact
that the Wagner leader
supposedly.
He did he did.
What is the term?
Hey, Google, what is the word
for when the ship's crew?
Through a mutiny, it's mutiny.
I don't know.
So it's mutiny.
I don't know, but I found these
results on search anyway.
So the biggest humiliation that
Putin ever had was the Mutiny
that the leader of a mercenary
unit.
This wasn't actually his troops.
These are mercs right for the
history of the world.
Mercs were bad.
I used to read Soldier of
Fortune in high school because I
thought mercenaries are not bad,
they're badass but you know, we
talked about what is it g or
what was it called Blackwater,
we talked about all of these
organizations is being shadowy
and terrible and monstrous and
you know we're talking about how
Wagner is going all over Africa
and so forth, killing people on
Moss and then Of course, Wagner
is being used as a, as a as an
additional force in Ukraine.
And everybody in the world is
like, mercenaries are terrible,
mercy.
And these are terrible, and then
when there's this Mutiny, oh,
mercenaries on the side of good.
They obviously hate what Putin
is doing.
They support Ukraine but
mercenaries aren't like that
mercenaries aren't at this were
an actual Mutiny of Of actual
generals and actual main Force,
Etc.
That would be different.
But this is the Mutiny of paid.
Mercs like, mercenaries are are
driven by money and hubris and
pride and they're not Patriots
their their paper trucks.
Pee pee, pee, pee a white rats.
They're Patriots their
Fairweather friends.
This Mutiny could have been
simple as Bull as one of an
oligarch or an American oligarch
or a political opponent, or a
tech bro.
Whoever could have said I'll
double whatever Putin's paying
you and the guys like okay, what
do you want me to do?
And so my response when
everybody was parroting and
echoing the this is the biggest
humiliation.
Ever to happen to Putin.
What I didn't say is, I don't
know if I'd be that you Millie
ated.
If a bunch of paid mercs turned
their back on me because you
just assume that the paid mercs
are going to be disloyal.
Like just assume that if you pay
somebody to love you they don't
actually love you.
It's like mercs are like whores
right mercs are whores.
Sorry mercs but your whores.
Pores will tell you, they love
you.
They'll give you a girlfriend
experience but they're still
whores and Whores could be boys
and girls, I'm not or they could
be theirs.
I'm not being sexist here,
whores, or whores or whores.
So, so I Mutiny by a whore is
not nearly as bad as a tu Brute,
a so, but it didn't happen
obviously.
Finally someone cut the check,
someone ven mode.
Someone wired something and it
all went away.
Maybe Belarus spotted Putin for
another trillion dollars maybe a
couple like maybe a couple
hundred Bitcoin, who knows,
maybe maybe Elon Musk did some
Dogecoin over to Wagner group to
make sure that it Go sideways
with nukes or maybe George Soros
Booga.
Booga Booga, who knows?
But whatever happened.
My response was.
If you think that's the, most
humiliating thing that's ever
happened to Putin.
How about you made a pledge with
George W?
George h.w., Bush, Senior and
you said, okay, I will be happy
to move forward, you know, close
all the books.
I'm sure everything's fine as
long as you promise, not to push
forth towards the border with
Russia.
Make sure at least have this
Ukrainian buffer State, you
know, maybe even just like, if
you really need to like Gun,
Boss is pretty great.
Like, we get along there, it's
all.
Don't forget.
Ukraine is Russian a holy land.
Ukraine was the birthplace of
entire Russian civilization.
Consider Ukraine a little bit
like, Jerusalem, right, for
Russians.
Ukraine is like, Jerusalem.
Ukraine is like, is like, is
like the is like Mecca, you
know?
Don't mess Ukraine.
Oh, okay.
No problem.
And then because we can't help
ourselves.
And because we are the global
hegemon, and Cuz nobody has
figured out that were a Colonial
Country and that we in that
Europe is our colony because we
own it because we pay for all of
their defense and that they are
in a and that they're sorry
about that.
And that they are kind of be,
he'll be beholden to us and sort
of a Faustian bargain and maybe
even Great.
Britain is part of the puppet
meister.
And all of these other things
that because we do color
revolutions and because we're
exporting democracy, which are
good, and because we're
exporting liberal democracy,
which is good, and because we're
exporting feminism, which is
good.
And feminism, is, is much more
sophisticated and modern and you
main, then then any of your mean
we, Love Muslims.
Don't get us wrong.
We love Catholics, don't get us
wrong and we love Buddhist.
Don't get us wrong and we love
Hindus.
Don't get us wrong, we love you.
But you're you are against human
nature and you are against human
freedom and you break every
single civil, right?
In the entire world.
And you are an offense of
humanity.
And, and if you don't support
gay marriage, and if you don't
support, The health care of
women in abortion and The
Liberation theology and black
liberation Theory and critical
race Theory even though these
things are brand-new and we just
sort of came up with them and
they've got a tinge of Marxism.
And and, and socialist ideology
on them, they got that stink.
It, even though they might be
materialists beliefs and even
though quietly you can hear Us
Des Facing the fact that you
believe in Sky, daddy, don't
mind any of that stuff.
And then all of a sudden,
collapses Falls and so forth,
fomenting what basically, our
vote based coup d'etat has and
then before, you know, it, the
new parliament's vote in NATO
and the EU and the Euro and
that's nothing like World War 2
and the hunger of Of Hitler for
the domination of other
countries because this is
opt-in, it's not opt out.
This is opt-in, just like the
Eugenics movement if you want to
abort your fetus, then that's
that's empowering.
If you want to start taking
hormonal therapies that make you
unable to have children ever.
That's not Eugenics.
That's, that's, that's your
decision.
That's or health care if you
want to end your life early
because you're extremely
depressed or you're getting old,
your quality of life is low
that's compassion, that's not
Eugenics.
That's not a genetic ethnic
cleansing, that is eight
empowerment agency choice.
So now Hungary and maybe Poland
And Russia and so forth.
They're getting you know to
extremist right there they're
showing that they like Sky Daddy
and they believe in Sky Daddy
and they honor Sky Daddy and
that they honor marriage,
traditional marriage between a
man and a woman, which of course
we call Dirty breeders.
April and they bristle at the
fact that children are trying to
be liberated into their, their
gender of choice and all these
things are too much for them.
They're not evolved enough,
they're not modern enough,
they're not, they're not awake
enough, they're not woke enough.
They haven't come to Jesus.
About the neoliberal.
They should be much Kinder
because this is a an inquisition
of shorts and in an inquisition,
everybody gives you an
opportunity to accept accept
Christ, right?
You Jewish?
Well, you're not Jewish anymore
or we're going to torture and
kill you and your family.
Oh, you're Muslim.
Well, you know, that's fine at
all but now you're Christian.
And now you're Catholic and if
you're not, then you and your
family will be killed.
Oh, you're you're, you're Hindu.
Oh, you're a Buddhist.
No.
Now you're Christian and you're
actually going to change your
name and I want one of your
son's for the, for this.
For the, the Seminary and and
one of your daughter's for the
nunnery because now you are
observant Catholics.
So there we are on a global
Inquisition.
It's I guess called the Democrat
Inquisition or the progressive
liberal, or modern liberal
Inquisition and we're going
around the world.
And we're saving Pagan babies,
not awful, like, saving Pagan
babies like those awful,
Colonial Christians who wanted
to destroy their natural
culture.
Their current culture and
replace it with Christianity.
But like the good thing which is
like, everybody can be any
gender they want.
Anybody should appreciate the
state more than the family.
Nobody should signify any type
of extremists, religion.
So no hijab.
All those other kinds of things
and then you two can be accepted
into the faith and not end up in
prison or dead, amen or
whatever.
Whatever materialistic gay men
is.
Huzzah maybe.
So the funny thing is about this
whole deal is while we were
completely asleep at the wheel.
Hey, Google win. did bricks
form, Bri CS The VR.
ICS was founded on June 16th
2009.
I also found an answer to this
question.
Where was the headquarter of
bricks?
Do you want to hear it?
Yes.
Shanghai on the website test
book.com they say the correct
answer is Shanghai.
BR ICS.
Headquarters is located in
Shanghai.
China pay, Google.
Tell me all about Bri CS.
According to Wikipedia VR, ICS
originally.
Named brick is an acronym for
the regional economies of
Brazil, Russia India and China
which in 2010 had included the
letter s for South Africa.
Tell me more about bricks.
According to Wikipedia, BR ICS
originally named brick is an
acronym for the regional
economies of Brazil, Russia
India and China which in 2010
had included the letter s for
South Africa.
Hey Gogol, how powerful is Bri
CS I don't know, but I found
these results on search.
The first result is the new
bricks.
Alliance is a mortal threat to
the West.
So while we weren't while we
were asleep at the wheel and
doing a bunch of internal Trump
hate.
And while we were having Trump
derangement syndrome, while
we're completely freaking out
and hitting the streets and
having our own domestic violence
the neighborhood was changing.
And the neighborhood was Is
changing too if you will rally
against this crazy country and
now all the countries that week
that we call second world or
developing world are uniting
against us and so now, hey
Google what's 20:23 - 2009?
I don't know but I found these.
Hey Google.
What's 2023 - 2009?
2023 - 2009 is 14.
So 14 years ago, bricks started
right.
Like in 13 years ago, South
Africa was added right?
And all of these countries are
extremely resource-rich.
China, for example, makes all of
our stuff and I learned
yesterday on a YouTube that the
only reason California is so
carbon neutral is because It
does all of its ugly stuff and
Mainland China.
And then ships, the finished
product, including large Works
pieces such as Bridges and so
forth after all of the smelting
and coal fired, electric fire
and all the awful stuff happens,
it cleans the blood off and then
delivers it to China.
And so I mean it's a California
and Ergo there is no carbon
offset required because all that
Was done NIMBY, not in my
backyard.
So you have China with huge
amounts of resources, right?
Let's go through brics Brazil,
because you is what we like to
call a shithole.
Favela country, full of sexy,
people who loves Jesus, who love
Jesus and you know, they are
multi-culti already there like a
really.
Extremely giant Cuba.
They're pretty Lawless they've
got huge gun laws, but they're
extremely resource-intensive.
They've got huge amounts of
resources.
There, a cornucopia of beauty
excitement and favelas.
I mean, we love them so much.
Actually they are Russia and
Brazil are more like America
than any other country on Earth.
So if you see a reflection
Brazil, Brazil has the
reflection that's multi-culti
and Lawless and Russia has the
reflection.
That's like proud uppity,
insane, and sickly drunk
addicted alcoholic and
Toothless, right?
So maybe the creativity, maybe
the depression and sadness,
maybe the hubris.
I think the hubris we get from
from Russia and the lawlessness.
We get from because you because
you so Brazil is the be, our is
school who ski whose ski is are.
So that's our another brother
from another mother.
And that is the country that
were hating on or We only hated
Manuel Emmanuel Goldstein.
I mean Voldemort Putin, I mean,
Vladimir Putin, we hate him.
We loved the Russian people.
We love the Russian people.
We hate Vladimir Putin, we love
the Russian people.
All right, so that's the, our
eye is India, India, right?
Are you starting to see that?
These are the people that we've
stomped all over, right?
Let's assume.
Zoom.
That.
That Britain is our double
secret, daddy, like Britain.
Actually, we know the
revolution, never really
happened.
It was all kind of a joke to
placate the natives and so like
Britain is always been our our
daddy but it's been switched
true.
It's like no, no, Britain is our
lap dog.
They're actually not.
Are our Puppet Master daddies.
So these are all countries that
that have been oppressed that
have been colonized that have
been destroyed that have been
under minded.
Every single one of them has
been at one point or another
shit-canned by Britain or
America or the EU, right?
Even.
I mean we America was pretty
much America Britain and Europe.
Pretty much collapsed South
Gotta buy the whole Nelson
Mandela Movement by the whole.
Like we divest our investment in
South Africa until until
apartheid is abolished.
And even me totally me totally
anti-apartheid, totally Pro
Nelson Mandela.
I mean, hey, but every action
has a reaction.
So, South Africa, right?
Right, and China, right?
So because you Russia, India,
China and Zhu, Zhu, de Africa,
whatever their their name is Za.
So there must be some Afrikaans,
hey, Google.
What's the name for a South
Africa in Afrikaans?
Here is your translation.
Sweet Africa, sweet Africa.
Hey Google.
Why is the top-level domains EA
for South Africa?
On the website Gandhi dotnet
they say Za domain.
Name, ending is an abbreviation
for zuid Africa.
The Dutch name for South Africa.
I also found an answer to this
question.
Why does South Africa use?
Saw.
Do you want to hear it?
Yes.
According to wikipedia.org
management, none of the official
names for South Africa can be
abbreviated to Za, which is an
abbreviation of the Dutch suid
Africa.
Dutch was considered an official
language in the union of South
Africa until 1961, it,
subsequently lost its synonymous
status with Afrikaans in 1983.
Thank you.
Happy to help.
Um, very interesting.
I thought it might have been
that.
So, that's a pretty big thing,
13, 14 years up until now, even
now nobody mentions that nobody
talks about it, they don't talk
about it, like a competitor,
they don't talk about it, like,
it's an opposition NATO or an
opposition EU or an opposition
West.
We talk about it dismissively
as, if it's some sort of loose
thing, kind of like a drinking
Club.
Hey Google, who invented the BR
ICS.
According to Wikipedia the
earliest fired Briggs appeared
in neolithic China.
Hey, Google, who invented Bri CS
The BR ICS has four Founders,
Russia China, India and Brazil.
Anyway.
Hey, Google.
What is the origin of the name?
Bri CS On the website guides dot
loc.gov, they say BR ICS is the
acronym denoting the emerging
National economies of Brazil,
Russia, India, China, and South
Africa.
The term was originally coined
in 2001 as Brick, by the Goldman
Sachs Economist Jim O'Neill in
his report building better,
global economic BR ICS.
I also found an answer to this
question.
Where did Bri CS originated?
Do you want to hear it?
Yes.
According to wikipedia.org the
original acronym.
Rick was coined in 2001 by
Goldman Sachs Economist Jim
O'Neill.
Who created the term to
describe, fast-growing economies
that were collectively dominate.
The global economy by 2050.
So 2001, it was invented.
Thank you. 2000 2001, it was
invented but it didn't actually
come into importance until a
number of years later, but it
was spoken into existence and
now it's a real thing.
Bricks has a lot of influence
and it's becoming stronger and
stronger to the point where
China has rushes back, right?
I don't know, but I found these
results.
Like China has Russians back
now.
In India, has rushes back and
Brazil has Russians rushes back
and even though nobody really
talks about it, Iran has rushes
back.
Iran has always had rushes back
because we've turned our back
and because there's so many
Financial sanctions on Iran,
there's Financial sanctions on
on Russia.
There are trade The tariffs on
China like when I was working
for new kind of me dot media.
I kind of had my eyeballs, much
more just 2017.
I had my eyeballs on on bitcoin
and a lot of the whales were, in
fact, China and Russia.
And they were doing huge Bitcoin
trades.
Outside of the official monetary
Three system, they were doing
billions of dollars, hundreds of
millions of dollars Bitcoin.
These whales were doing Bitcoin
trades, back and forth to each
other, to buy, and sell things
outside of the official trade
sanctions and so forth in.
So, there is a grey economy and
even more, I don't know if I
said this told the story about
in, 96, I met an oil broker, who
was the cousin of the woman?
I was traveling with on, on Hoss
is her name now and and and and
Harry and Broussard and
Broussard.
Now, she's an Haas and her
cousin was a oil broker and he
has an American passport, but he
was telling me that he broke
There is all different countries
that have sanctions on them.
Guaranteed not allowed to broker
oil.
Brokered oil with Cuba broke it
oil with Iran broker dayron oil.
Broker to Rack oil brokered like
all kinds of oil Venezuelan oil
when there were sanctions on
them.
And he's like, you know, all we
did was we, you know, I guess
I'm using a term but the term
I'm using is d cantered.
Which is to say you took the
original bottle that had, you
know, Iran on it and you poured
the oil into a into a fresh
vessel which didn't have any
Iran on it.
It had Saudi Arabia or or
whatever.
So, you just like, re bottle re
bottle, re bottle, take the, and
delivered, a Cuba to do this.
And that, it's just like World
War 2 when the Germans had to
decide whether or not a ship
was, in fact, Filled with
passengers or filled with
Munitions before they torpedoed
them.
So they ended up torpedoing
everybody because they just
assumed everything was a ruse,
there is an entire extra
National economy.
That goes on completely.
Ignoring American sanctions,
American limits, American
tariffs, American blockades, and
whatever.
There's a giant middle finger
going off.
There's an equivalent.
Of the dark web with regards to.
What do we call the Dark World
where you know every country
that's being sanctioned is
pleading poor mouth, while
secretly flush with cash.
You can't assume that just
because someone's swatting, the
ground singing uncle, uncle
uncle that they are in secretly.
Scrooge.
McDuck swimming around in their
own, giant pit of money.
Jewels and gold, and platinum,
and silver, and diamonds,
whatever.
So anyway, this is a super long
episode.
It's like a million hours long.
So I will hereby stop now and
hope you enjoyed it and want you
to know that even though I'm not
I'm told by Jason that the
reason why everybody shitting
all over me about my neutral.
Port.
My support of Tassie Tulsi
gabbard, I love her.
I completely support John F
Robert F, Kennedy jr.
I completely support, Jimmy
Dore, I love Tucker Carlson.
I think that, that Elon Musk is
a mensch.
I think that Joe Rogan is an
awesome guy.
I adore.
Adam, Curry, i.org.
But hates Adam Carolla.
I adore John.
See Dvorak.
I love to listen to Glenn Beck
once in a while.
I'll even pop into info info
wars to hear what?
What crazy Alex Jones is saying,
um, You know, I'm just, like, I
try to piss everybody off by
going into Sputnik and Artie and
sharing those articles and
people shit themselves.
Like, I can't tell you how much
I've been blocked.
My instance, for Mastodon is
Abraham .su, and even that is a
flex towards you guys are so
stupid.
The Cold War died.
Hey Google.
How many years ago did the Cold
War die?
According to Wikipedia, Cold War
1985 to 1991, the time period of
around 1985 to 1989.
Mark, the final period of the
Cold War.
Hey, Google, how many years
since 1989?
on the website, how long ago
go.com they say 1989 was 33
years, five months, and 25 days
ago, which is 12,000, 229 days,
33 is the magic number 33 is the
magic number.
So, based on that, 33 years ago,
man, the Soviet Union went kaput
and so I went onto my registrar
that I discovered in Berlin and
I registered but a ham .s u s--
u stands for Google.
What does the top level domain
Su stand for I don't know, but I
found these results on search.
Su is the internet country code.
Top-level domain that was
designated for the Soviet Union
on 19, September 1990.
So I have to .su domains, I have
abdeslam, I've always wanted
like I've always been envious of
people.
Like Adam add Curry.com right?
That's actually as email address
Adam at Curry.com.
I admire anybody who's got their
first name at last.
Name.com.
So obviously that's not possible
because the name Abraham or
Oppenheimer is is like, hey,
Google who is the prophet
Abraham.
According to Wikipedia Abraham
is the common Hebrew patriarch
of the abrahamic religions
including Judaism Christianity
and Islam.
Thank you.
Just doing my job.
So being that Abraham is the
patriarch of Judaism
Christianity and Islam.
It's hard to find anything
Abraham anything right?
Couldn't find anything anything
until I found the fact that
Godless people.
The so V is it's a perfect?
Perfect Crime.
Not only was was the Soviet
Union Godless Communists and
materialists but the country
died in 1990 right or 1991 or
night, whatever.
Whenever the Soviet Union died
and went away and broke up into
the Russian Federation at all,
nobody cared about the Su
top-level domains.
So it's mostly been caught in
Amber and I I took the Mastodon
out of Amber.
I took the Mastodon, if you will
out of ice out of permafrost, I
took the Macedon out of
permafrost and reanimated it
into abadan.
MM .s you so now, if you email
me at chris@hildebrandlaw.com or
you go to Abraham .s U / at
Chris, you'll find my Mastodon
instance.
So I am constantly.
Like giving you the finger all
of you because of your crazy
crazy obsession with needing to
find an external enemy and you
need to find an external enemy.
That's not China because we love
China long time and we just
can't we can't hate on a place.
That's so essential for our
quality of life, and the fact
that we're going to off We're
going to NIMBY our entire
country into China, not in my
backyard, not in my USA but
we're going to Coal fire in
China.
We're going to gas fire.
We're going to Frack.
We're going to Nuke.
We're going to do everything.
We're going to allow those
people to suck in.
Soot suck it in soot and then
we're going to be a graceful
little Older, whatever.
Battery solar wind Utopia here.
We're just gonna Bogart all of
our petroleum reserves and all
of our abiotic oil and all of
our we're going to give another
30 to 50 years to let all of the
oil abiotic.
Lee, fill back up all of the
wells that we've depleted over
the last 100 years, and then
everything will be perfect.
And hopefully, the, according to
the crazy Secret eugenicist.
America and our elk are, you
know, hopefully by then, though
only be a population of, you
know, 2.5 billion people because
of a bunch of global oopsies.
But none of it's our fault, just
Global oopsies and then maybe
when we're down to 500 million
or a billion or a couple few
billion people we can start
drilling baby Drilling and then
we can start driving around our
Lambos Ferraris hypercars.
Puh-puh-puh, Gatti's, and
Porsche 918.
S and all those other fun things
without worrying about the
environment.
Amen.
Frederick payment purposes.
Oh, and I got to tell you if I
have any recommendations for
you, watch Wag the Dog.
Read Wag the Dog, the book,
awesome.
But that was when I was thinking
about what I was thinking about
is Is something I completely
forgot about.
So completely had a brain fart.
Don't remember that at all?
Oh, sweet Universe.
Why did you take that?
Thought from my head was it too
bombastic when it get me
disappeared?
I don't know.
What was I thinking?
My well, if I think about it I
will put it into the next
episode but oh oh, I remember if
you can If you want, if you if
you mail me a thumb drive, I
have every single episode of The
Art Bell show from coast to
coast, I've every single episode
of my hard drive and you're
welcome to it.
If you send me a thumb drive to
my address, but every Saturday
at 9 p.m.
Eastern time.
There's somewhere in time, I
think it's what it's called
Somewhere in Time.
Hey Google, what are the weekly
Saturday episodes with our bail?
Is it called back in time or
somewhere in Time?
According to Wikipedia classic
episodes of Coast to Coast, AM
can be heard in some radio
markets on Saturday nights under
the name Somewhere in Time
hosted by Bell.
Thank you.
Not a problem.
So every Saturday, every
Saturday at 9 p.m. if I'm home I
will always find A radio show.
I will always find a radio
station that I can stream.
That has Somewhere in Time with
Art Bell and they will replay
episodes from the 90s and 2000's
and you'll start to realize when
you Peg your reality on what
people were saying in the 90s
and you realize that it's the
same old recycled crap.
You the the the scales will fall
from your eyes, the most
revolutionary Act.
That you can do in the entire
world is get, is send me a USB
drive.
I will fill it with every Art
Bell episode and listen to it
and realize that this is all
recycled stuff, all the
apocalypse apocalypse,
apocalyptic ISM, all the the the
the Russia Panic, all the Putin
Panic, all the North Korea
panic, The, you know, Ted
Kaczynski stuff, all the fears
of of white supremacy.
All the fears of climate
collapse.
All the all the Al Gore stuff is
like, fresh in the 90s you will
have your, you will poop
yourself, your head will
explode, your wig will go flying
off.
So make sure you don't wear your
wig in public with these in your
earphones.
Go back and consume all the
episodes and there's a million
of them of the Art Bell show
from coast to coast.
Hey Google.
What year?
What years did Art Bell?
Do his radio show.
According to Wikipedia his
original 1978, late-night Las
Vegas program on K.
TW n was a political call in
show under the name.
West Coast AM in 1988 Bell and
Ellen Corbett renamed, the show
Coast to Coast AM and moved its
broadcast from The Plaza Hotel
in Las Vegas to Bells Home in
Pahrump.
I also found an answer to this
question.
What happened to our fellows
wife?
Do you want to hear it?
No.
Okay.
Hey Google.
What year?
Did Art Bell?
Host Coast to Coast AM.
I don't know, but I found these
results on search.
Hey, Google, what years, did Art
Bell, host Coast to Coast AM I
don't know, but I found these
results on search.
I don't know.
Hey Google.
What year did Art Bell?
Stop hosting Coast to Coast AM
regularly.
I don't know, but I found these
results.
Unicorn.
All right.
Well, doesn't matter.
You should do it.
That's your task.
Till next time I love you, I
believe in you.
I want the best for you.
God bless you and Godspeed to
you.
Talk to you soon.
Ciao.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.